our first actress it's her third visit
to Hall age in the last couple of days
which i think is some sort of record
you'll see her this fall in Hunger Games
Mockingjay part 2 and a little movie
called Star Wars The Force awakens but
you know and levar is the great and
noble Brienne of Tarth on Game of
Thrones please welcome
Madeline Christine
our next actress is probably the only
one who can make us forget about Captain
America playing a 1940's spy who always
knows her own value from Marvel's agent
Carter please welcome Hayley Atwell
we've been waiting a really long time
for the right woman to step into Wonder
Woman's boots from the upcoming Batman
vs Superman please welcome gal gadot
next up is the teacher who's been
schooling the doctor and the ways of
humanity please welcome from Doctor Who
Jenna Coleman and last and certainly not
least because I don't even know where to
start with this next actress from
hobbling James Caan and misery to
commanding the room as a disembodied
head an American Horror Story coven to
rocking the bearded look on freakshow
this oscar-winning actress is an
ass-kicking icon please welcome Kathy
Bates
everybody loves happy baby i love you
community thank you look hi everybody
welcome thanks for being here this has
been such a great time this year for
interesting and complex female
characters like yours and you are the
women that young girls are now looking
up to so I wanted to start by hearing
Hoover the ass-kicking characters and
pop culture that inspired you when you
were growing up who wants to start was
gonna go first I'll start there we go
I'm gonna go with Betty Davis because
she had gravitas she was complicated
formidable notorious incredibly talented
bold opinionated at a time when that
didn't really seem to be the norm for
women and they she was in every role
that I saw her play she was dynamic and
quite brilliant and I just fell in love
with her really good one good one I'm
gonna go for my mother my EEMA um well
she really gave me and my sister she has
given me and my sister everything that
made us who we are today I think the key
thing is endless love but she oh she
always made us feel like we were the
best
and um may she always making us believe
in and believe in ourselves and follow
our dreams and work hard so this one is
for Miami okay um for me I always
admired this particular woman that when
I was young and watching films seemed to
be outside of the norm and seemed to be
something that maybe I could aspire to
maybe I could follow which was Sigourney
Weaver in Ailee
because of that strength and power but
not forsaking her femininity and and
good old-fashioned ass-kicking I always
enjoyed Katharine Hepburn and bringing
up baby not being afraid to ask
questions not being afraid to persevere
and to have a mind and a voice I love
that film Cathy do you have one does
Ghandi count um I think I would have to
go with what God said my mother was a
real ass kicker too um even though she
was born in 1907 she was a real tough
character and she taught me to be tough
and I wouldn't be sitting here today in
front of all of you all if it hadn't
been for her so I was wondering if any
of you were gonna say Wonder Woman
I would agree to go because I think a
lot of us probably also looked up to
Wonder Woman growing up and I just
wanted to hear from you what it was like
to put on Wonder Woman's costume the
very first time Wow Wow where do I begin
um so basically three days after I got
cast for the movie they flew me to
Michigan and I got into this for fitting
and I got us into this huge room filled
of images of me as Wonder Woman it blew
my mind and then we got into another
room and then I saw the costume for the
first time and we tried it on and it was
like an out-of-body experience because
there I was little girl from Israel
becoming Wonder Woman so it and I love
it and I love the way the cut they made
the costume look I think it's so I think
it really represents the Wonder Woman of
today and I'm very very grateful to be
the one who's gonna bring her to life
yep yeah you're too
that you didn't even know that was the
part you were auditioning for when you
first audition oh yeah no no I did so
two years ago I was in Los Angeles and
they told me that they wanted Warner
Brothers wanted to see me to addition me
too
they wanted me to addition to something
I didn't know what it was uh and I did
an addition and I didn't know what it
was for and got back to Israel and
everything was great and then Zack
Snyder the fabulous director called me
and he was like well we're gonna need to
see you for camera test do you know what
you're testing for and I said no and he
said do you have Wonder Woman in Israel
my jaw dropped
I I was dead for a second and then I
came back to life and I and I tried to
put on my best cool voice and I was like
yeah of course yeah and um and and and
that that was it and yeah that's great
the rest is history Gwendolyn I know
that you are not allowed to tell us
anything really about Star Wars
or your character but I do want to know
if you could tell us if she could take
Brienne in a fight of course is that too
secretive that might be sufficient
impossible I think it would be like two
worlds meeting and possibly just merging
and becoming one
ha ha ha ha ha all right yeah it's great
um you know we all love Brienne and you
know everyone feels so strongly about
her and we all want really great things
for her I think because she's such it's
true
and I know that this is not possible but
if you could write the rest of brand's
story what would her happy ending but
could load your questions a tough on um
well I think where we've seen Brienne up
to this point that we have loved her
because she's so dedicated to an
overriding sense of moral good that she
she pledges an oath to Catelyn Stark to
return the stark girls to safety and
that moment in the final episode oh gosh
spoiler alert but then there's something
involving a candle and it isn't good um
but I think what we'd like to see now is
we'd really like to see her redeem
herself again but what I love about that
terribly disappointing incident did was
it although Brienne of Tarth is a
character in a show but it made us see
her humanity and how we all fail and
even the strongest badass women fail and
as long as you try and redeem yourself
again and keep going and try to achieve
your goals in pursuit of the greater
good then that's all you can do right
that's great do perfectly well I was
wondering also because I feel like you
know there must be a sense of ownership
for all of you when you're playing your
characters and I was wondering is there
ever been a time when you've had to say
to a showrunner or to a director I don't
think she would say this I don't think
that she would do that
of course yeah oh really no now I get it
more as a mother I have a three-year-old
daughter and for me responsibility is
something that goes hand in hand with my
with a development with my character
development and luckily I was I was able
to communicate all the problems I had
with my characters with the directors
that have worked with and there were all
men
and and we always made it better and
figured it out um so yes definitely I
think no anyone else jump in come on um
it's not so much as things that she
wouldn't say but it often involves me
just going I don't think she would be
naked in this scene there's no need for
that and I'm not doing it just fulfill
your weird little fantasy um Haley was
it important for you and your
showrunners to really like what was
important to bring out with Peggy when
you brought her out from the Captain
America where all the terone show well
she didn't have much screen time on cap
the First Avenger I mean we got a sense
of she was capable and she was strong
and she was kick-ass and she was tough
but I just felt that that's kind of um
that kind of didn't really do her much
service or um or justice really because
in in the show my main thing was being
able to show the vulnerabilities of her
what the psychological and immuno tional
cost of of grieving over Steve and also
trying to make her way in the world and
I think for me as well you're playing
this kind of walk well it Wendelin was
saying playing these incredibly strong
characters but that doesn't necessarily
mean that they don't find life
incredibly difficult and hard and it's
almost impossible to maintain that sense
of empowerment all the time and I wanted
to show a side of Peggy that really
struggled and had moments of isolation
and self-doubt because I think that's
something that every person on the
planet to their own extent can relate to
and that makes her so much more human
and appealing to an audience yeah I
agree with that now I have to ask you I
learned while researching there's a
group of fans called the Cardinal
shippers yeah would you care to explain
what it is and did it surprise you and
that started to happen ah so Carson
Ellie is basically they still don't
quite understand the word shipping but I
suppose it's a nice thing but they'd
love the idea of and
the waitress whose cart his friend and
Carter herself to have a bit of a lovin
I suppose and which was you know
fantastic and I think one of the reasons
is not just kind of the you know the the
enjoyment of what that would be but I
think it's quite rare
on television these days to see women
who are in a scene together not talking
about the men having women who are
talking to get genuinely loving each
other supporting each other caring for
each other and not in competition with
each other not being Cassey and battling
but have a genuine affection for each
other and I think that was a very
important part for Lyndsy Fonseca and
myself to bring out as a genuine
relationship there which is something
that again I can relate to my own life
with my own girlfriends and I think that
kind of natural affection meant that you
know luckily the fans took that
relationship into their hearts and then
they just want them to case so it always
ends haha um Cathy disembodied head
beard what does Ryan Murphy have in
store for you you haven't started for
your next um I don't know this last
season I was just afraid after they
wrapped the chains around my head and it
popped off I was terrified somebody was
gonna have to pick it up and drag it
around with them that season um yeah I
can't I just really gotten the first
couple of scripts of hotel um I know I'm
I know I'm running the hotel which is
very exciting that'll be fun
and I know I say this every season but I
don't know how our writers do it they've
just created it completely different
it's almost like a completely different
way of telling a story with wonderful
characters everybody's just gonna be
knocked out of their seats when they see
this so I don't know if my head will
play in any part of that I haven't
gotten that far but um I've had a blast
working on the show so I just feel very
very lucky yeah
you've done so much in both TV and film
and I'm wondering if you feel like
there's one or the other that's more
hospitable some women nowadays well you
talked earlier about kicking ass and
it's wonderful that gal is getting to
play a kick-ass lady and a lot of these
young women here um I think it's you
know when you're in a big film like that
it's wonderful to have a really kick-ass
part and I think a lot of us are going
to television because the writing is so
wonderful now and it's just a place for
all of us as actors to get to play dream
characters that many of us wouldn't have
an opportunity to do and it's it's fun I
mean I worked with Dustin Hoffman years
and years ago and he gave me my first
job really as a character on T on his
first movie that my first movie with him
and he said recently that you know
movies have kind of you know it's not as
interesting for actors unless you can
play these big parts but TV is where
it's really at now that it's a writing
is great and anyway I guess I've said it
what about the rest of you do you do
have a feel of one versus the other
for TV and film iris it's nice to have
more than 90 minutes or more than two
hours with a character you know you get
to go through seasons or you get to have
12 episodes to really play and explore
and throw into different situations so
that's the really nice thing about TV
and a TV series I suppose yeah yeah
gonna say something yeah no I thinks
exactly what I think as well or yes all
you mother oh it's um I think it feels
like this a new golden age for
television and a lot of people in the
film industry are coming to television
the people have written films you know
writing TV now and directors and actors
it's there's no longer a stigma attached
by going you're either a TV actor or a
movie actor you can you can do both
um and I think it's I think there is
just you get more of them yeah an
opportunity to explore a character over
a longer period of time
yeah Jenna Clara started off as such a
sort of mysterious figure and now that
she shed some of that she's a fully
actualized woman and I was wondering was
there a moment for you and a script
about you were shooting when you feel
like she really came alive for you I
have to say the first season for me was
so fun because I got to UM I got to play
three different versions of essentially
the same character welcome to her sci-fi
and it's kind of imagining the exact
same essence of a character but if they
had grown up in Victorian England if
they had grown up in future space or if
they'd grown up right now in
contemporary London so that was really
fun the first series by suppose actually
going to see the day in and day out and
school teacher and her on her home life
and explore that kind of domestic
element and then see her go off into the
epic those two contrasting things are
quite interesting I think and I'm
curious and everything that we saw our
season with master and Missy what are
your thoughts about a woman maybe one
day playing the doctor I think is
obviously I think it's absolutely
possible and there's absolutely no
reason why not and the doctor is
obviously Time Lord as is the master but
I think a Peter Capaldi is doing the
most wonderful job so there isn't
currently a vacancy and be I think it
depends on the person actually and it
depends on where what direction the show
is going to take and and I think Steven
Moffat right in that he casts the person
at the right time in which to send the
show in a certain direction so of course
it's absolutely possible and I'm sure
will happen at some point
yeah I've been any volunteers from this
panel I think work out well right I'm
curious because there has been so much
improvement from women in the industry
and there's been a lot of attention this
year on changing things for equality but
I am curious to know what challenges
you've faced
taste that maybe your male counterparts
have not having to run in heels yeah
that's the main one that's nothing I can
speak for myself but luckily I never
experienced such thing and I've been
working in a very male-dominated
environment shooting The Fast and the
Furious franchise and Superman versus
Batman and I was privileged enough to be
working with men who has a lot of
respect for women
having said that I always feel like
women don't get the same volume the same
space as men do and that's why it's
always so important for me to show the
cooler side of women to show the strong
women the amazing side of women it was
never about women versus men because I
love them both but it it was always
about showing how amazing we are cuz we
are yeah you are
I have to say I found it incredibly
difficult I found that the initially
when I left drama school the world was
10 years ago the world was a less
embracing place than it is now because I
don't think the internet was so
available to everybody and the Internet
I feel seems to have made people's frame
of reference so much more diverse and as
a consequence what we're seeing is
characters like the ones that all the
women here play are being embraced
because women want to see themselves
being more represented in a more
realistic way I think right and and not
just women men everybody wants to see
something we're all so unique that
that's what we want to see and we want
to see people that we can relate to or
people that are so vastly different from
us that somehow through the journey of
storytelling we find out we're not so
different after all
and and I do feel that starting to
happen
and I'm I'm very grateful for that Bravo
any anybody else no I didn't add a
follow that that was extraordinary yeah
it's hard to follow that I'm being told
we're gonna go to the audience for an
audience Q&A so line up if you have a
question for these women
I think we're someone coming sorry I'm
actually really nervous I'm a big fan of
like gal gadot and Hayley Atwell and I
know sweet dumpy we're nervous - it's
all good let's just breathe so I
recently I bought a Wonder Woman shirt
recently and a lot of people have met
with it with a lot of antagonizing and
telling me how it's wrong and I
shouldn't be able to wear it why why do
you think I tell them why can't women
can wear Batman shirts but I can't wear
Wonder Woman of course you can again of
course you can it's just it's just
really hard someone told me you're
really brave to wear that Wonder Woman
shirt and it just felt so you know huh
the energy needs a lot about his
confidence in his sexual you know
and I just wanted to know what you guys
you know because I also want to get a
Peggy Carter bringing of Tarth on
Captain phasma what you guys think of
all that well you're gonna be the
inspiration you're gonna be the hero
that says generator and the trendsetter
exactly yeah so we we love you your
folks a hearing agent cutter and Wonder
Woman and Brienne all say that to me
makes me like I'm real and now we can
fly too
he'll never I won't try but thank you so
much I appreciate it thank you
you're doing well Hey ladies
hello hi
I actually have a shirt of the women who
kick ass that I like some of them um but
so settled right so elegant women who
kick ass yeah definitely um you're huge
inspirations all of you I enjoy you so
much uh I have a question for God yes
nice pronunciation M at Sochi I see the
tamazaki Iago yeah McGee they like le PO
a facade the avocado lost at a massage
artists if he knew mama D Nocturna salon
is my lady new Hollywood yeah you're
gonna have to let CT share this oblique
total a massage you want to ask the
question yeah okay so can i you guys ads
yeah I said that I think that God made
the the biggest journey I mean no
offense to you ladies but we have a very
small country and to break out of it
it's exponentially I'm think I'm using
that right
I'm harder so I wanted her to tell us a
little bit about that journey and I was
just so moved by the fact that someone
just Oh keep her to me um I gotta tell
you that I I really believe now
that it doesn't matter where you come
from and how small the country you're
coming from is or as long as you aspire
thing as long as you dream and you aim
hides all the cliches are right really
and I think that if you're persistent
and if you're good and if you're trying
your best and being proactive at the end
of the day for me because I've tried for
years I've been doing this for eight
years and really now this is my the
biggest thing for me and I really feel
that it's a combination of being
prepared and having the opportunity and
a lot of luck and having all of this
elements together at the right moment so
I'm very grateful um and I do think that
everyone can achieve their dreams I do
it sounds so bad but I do good I'll if
I'm wrong with it uh hi I'm Jess my
question is for Gwendolyn and Haley so
you both play characters that are a bit
out of time and there are other
characters as typically men but
occasionally women who don't treat you
like we T treat other women today um and
I know that you as a character have to
respond accordingly
but are there ever instances where you
you want to respawn in your own manner
and if so how all the time with violence
yeah
that's a joke well I think one of the
things I like about the way that Peggy
deals were there is it she's very
resourceful and she uses what she has
around her and her quality so she uses
her it her violence yes but her wit and
her charm and her intelligence and at
times when she needs to her sexuality
but she doesn't completely depend upon
it
so she's dynamic in that way and I think
that I look up to the you know the way
the writers have created her as someone
you know who who is complicated and
multifaceted and has the ability to
stand up for who she is and she says to
know her value and I think it's inspired
me to try and do the same but also you
know you can't play a character like
that we're within an industry that
doesn't support that character and we
thing with Marvel is that they've been
incredibly supportive of me as an actor
and I don't feel like I'm an actress
coming I feel actually that kind of
transcends that I feel genderless I felt
I feel seen and recognized as a human
being independent of my sex and and
that's the reason why they've been able
to create Peggy Carter is because that's
what they also stand for
Oh Ben what hi I'm Jane and my question
is to everybody who is kicking ass up
there so what is the most challenging
stunts action you have ever did yourself
on set and what's the stories behind it
and what's the story behind it was that
yeah yeah and yet and also like the
stories behind it Kathy do you want to
talk about wrestling james caan yeah
well I that's the first thing that um
probably that was the hardest thing I
ever had to do and Dave Ellis our stunt
director and coordinator we actually
worked on the stunts even before we
started filming and it was tough we used
you know standings but a lot of stuff we
did ourselves and the hardest part was
getting my head slammed into the floor
how was hard I didn't think I would cry
a tenth of that but I did so I guess
that was the hardest you know that I've
ever had to do next yeah yeah well I did
a I think it's Episode five of the first
season and there's a fight sequence in a
diner that Peggy does and I was wearing
you know the Staton the stockings this
the Spanx the slip the mic pack that
harness this pencil skirt the heels and
and I also I mean that's challenging
physically but then I also kind of I
learnt these flight sequences as kind of
dance routines almost there kind of
choreographed in that way and then you
put them together and throw a punch in
and it becomes kind of an aggressive
fight scene but I do remember doing this
one move where I had to duck and I was
and I kept on doing this kind of move
where it's a bit like oh I'm the stunt
dog with the stunt coordinator him
actually issues like darling you're not
in a club well there she was she's
Americans who didn't sound that oh she's
like darling you're not in the club
she and so I like [ __ ] I just like oh
yeah of course
sorry but because she planted that seed
in my head the camera rolled and I just
had Nicki Minaj's anaconda in my head
whole sequence so when I look back at
that sequence that's all I'm thinking
about um that was so strictly heard one
I think mine probably been um I've been
hanging upside down a lot which sounds
quite easy um but it's not and um it's
what happens is you only get to hang
upside down in like 30 seconds birds and
we had about a 12-page scene and we were
actually in Tenerife at high altitudes
as well and so we managed to get through
the day but apparently it wasn't as hard
for me but the actor I was working with
now has like this intense fear of upside
down people and feels that she has to
talk really really quickly and gets her
a scene because you could kind of just
see blood pouring to the head I think um
aspect so that's probably mine
gwendlyn do you have one I I do I think
it's definitely Brian's fight with the
Hound and that was the most grueling
fight we spent two months training for
it and we trained three or four days a
week for six to eight hours a day just
trying to build up the strength
necessary to carry out the fight to
fight Rory McCann who's a six foot seven
man that's certainly a lot stronger than
I am but the characters are of the same
level of strength so I had to do quite a
lot of pretending to try and carry that
one off but but more than that exactly
as you say you learn the fight as a
dance and then it's actually the story
that you're telling that infuses it with
something else and we were always very
aware it was a story that was happening
and we learnt this in the stunt tent in
Belfast on a level floor in a tent we
got to the location
and I was running backwards
sword-fighting up a hill it was also
freak weather conditions in Iceland it
was boiling hot ah and I had the real
armor on the the face was Casa rolling
in the Sun and and the there was one
moment if you're familiar with the fight
where Brienne punches the hound um
somewhere extremely intimate and we do
you know we'd rehearsed it so we knew
where where that punch went how we did
it so it was fake so no one got hurt and
then just before the take Rory McCann
said do it for real and I said I I'm
sorry
and he said do it for real and what you
see in that fight is a genuine
connection of fist and undercarriage
oh we have time for one more one more
question okay this question goes to Gaul
yes um so there have been pink firm
invisible jet just kidding okay okay
good because either way um haha there's
been a lot of iterations of one Roman
throughout the source material of your
character um did you have any difficulty
researching your part or isn't is there
a particular Wonder Woman story you
enjoyed or feature one oh wow uh well
with with this movie I came you're so
sweet I miss my daughter um with this
movie I was lucky enough to well Zack
Snyder is a master when it comes to this
Jean er is a master period uh so he
structured the whole idea of the Wonder
Woman of today he knows what he wants
and he knows how to get it and after I
was Kent after they cast me for the role
we had a lot of discussion about who
should be the best
Wonder Woman of today I cannot say much
because they still need you guys to go
and see the movie but I can just say
that I was very very privileged to do to
go through this beautiful interesting
research with Zack and I just can't wait
for you guys to see what we've made for
you and there's so much more to come um
but it's it's inspiring for me she's in
the [ __ ] I I'm inspired by Wonder Woman
I go to bed and I dream of her but um
it's amazing it's gonna be good foot
foot it's gonna be great ha ha ha well
we're all expired by all of you let me
to pick ass thank you so much for all
coming thanks so much thanks
you
you